hello everyone welcome to this video on
optimizing clusters and workloads for
reliability and cost efficiency using
workload right sizing
cost optimization in kubernetes can be
complex and you don't want your actions
to negatively impact your application's
performance and reliability
so to help you optimize your kubernetes
clusters and workloads we have
identified the following golden signals
which allow you to run reliable
performant and cost efficient workloads
on kubernetes
check out the links in the description
to see a video overview of the golden
signals in this video we will explore
the First Signal workload right sizing
the content creator for this course is
Samara Casa who is a technical account
manager from Google Cloud Consulting
Samara curated the information in this
video to give you a deeper understanding
of optimizing your kubernetes clusters
and workloads for reliability and cost
efficiency
let's Dive Right In over the next few
minutes we will explore workload right
sizing resource requests and limits and
their role in right sizing
some of the tools available in gke to
help you with workload right sizing and
some resources for you to follow up with
so what does workload right sizing mean
workload right sizing is the process of
adjusting the size of resources to match
your actual usage
this can not only help you save money
but can also improve the performance of
your applications
workload resource requests are often
substantially over provisioned right
sizing is the biggest opportunity to
reduce resource waste and to control
costs to avoid over-provisioning you
should first raise awareness within
technical teams about the importance of
setting resource requests and then focus
on right sizing your workloads
next let's discuss resource requests and
limits
to reduce resource waste and avoid
intermittent issues with performance and
reliability it is critical to understand
your application capacity requirements
to appropriately set resource requests
let's investigate how resource requests
play a prominent role in making your
applications reliable performant and
cost effective
kubernetes uses CPU and memory requests
for bin packing scheduling cluster Auto
scaling and horizontal workload Auto
scaling and resource requests to
classify a pod's quality of service qos
class
when kubernetes creates a pod it assigns
one of these quality of service classes
to the pod
ernetes relies on the pod's quality of
service class to make decisions about
which pods should be immediately killed
when a given node's utilization
approaches its capacity if resource
requests are not set best effort class
is assigned to the pods whenever
kubernetes needs to reclaim resources at
node pressure without any warning or
graceful termination best effort pods
are the first to be killed potentially
causing disruption to the overall
application
now there might be certain scenarios
where you consciously use the best
effort quality of service class to
maximize resource utilization
the key here is that it's a conscious
decision
in essence there's nothing wrong with
using the best effort quality of service
class as long as you understand Its
Behavior and its outcomes
note that if you think the best effort
class is not appropriate to your
workloads and you do not want kubernetes
to assign best effort class to your pods
you can create guard rails either in the
CI CD pipeline or within the kubernetes
cluster
when you've correctly set resource
requests kubernetes scheduler can use
them to decide on which node to place
your pod
this guarantees that pods are being
placed in nodes that make them function
normally leading to better workload
stability and reduced resource waste
defining resource limits helps ensure
that the application never uses all the
available underlying infrastructure
provided by the Computing nodes note
that if you have burstable workloads a
best practice is to set container
resources to use the same amount of
memory for requests and limits and a
larger or unbounded CPU limit
figuring out actual used requested and
allocated resources at scale is
difficult but here's some good news
when you run a workload on gke you can
use the cost optimization insights
feature to understand workload specific
resource requests suggestions and
workload right sizing opportunities
right in the console as you can see here
the bar charts represent the
relationship between usage requests and
limits for a defined time window
dark green represents CPU and memory
usage
light green represents CPU and memory
requests
gray represents CPU and memory limits
and yellow represents scenarios in which
CPU and memory usage exceeds requests
if an entire bar is dark green this
means that you don't have requests set
for a workload which is not a best
practice
if there's too much light green next to
dark green you may have workloads that
are over provisioned during the defined
time window
a yellow bar indicates requests are not
set high enough for a workload which can
be a performance and reliability risk
these color codes make it easier to
quickly identify workloads that need
requests and limits tuned for either
cost optimization stability or
reliability
in scenarios where you need to increase
or reduce CPU and memory requests gke
integrates recommendations from the
kubernetes vertical pod Auto scaler vpa
directly into its workload console on a
specific workloads page navigate to
workloads actions scale scale compute
resources
remember that these recommendations are
based on historical usage data so it's
important to coordinate with workload
owners to ensure that the suggestions
make sense for the workloads
you can also enable vertical pod Auto
scaling to automatically update the
resource requests that best fit the
needs of your workloads based on the CPU
and memory usage
to configure vertical pod Auto scaling
navigate to the workloads actions Auto
scale vertical pod Auto scaling you can
also use cloud monitoring dashboard for
gke to get visibility into your
kubernetes workloads Cloud monitoring
dashboard for gke offers you a
comprehensive view of your gke clusters
from many different projects
this will enable you to manage your
workloads by identifying performance
risks for best effort and burstable
workloads
Additionally you can set up alerts for
your workloads to notify you when
they're at risk for performance and
reliability
in this video you learned about the
importance of setting resource requests
for performant and reliable applications
in addition you learned how configuring
appropriate requests can help reduce
resource waste and decrease costs check
out the links in the description to
learn more about right sizing your
workloads and to try tools and
techniques to optimize your workloads
we hope you found this video helpful
check out the links in the description
to view a video on how to reduce costs
by scaling down clusters during low
demand periods without compromising
application reliability and performance
thanks for watching
to learn more check out our special
report on the state of kubernetes cost
optimization which is a cloud agnostic
quantitative research study based on
anonymized real-world usage data the
report examines how kubernetes
capabilities and signals can help
identify key areas you should prioritize
to achieve greater reliability and cost
efficiency check the description for the
link